pour l'instant
compte ne sont pas arrêtés
quand ils sont pas arrêtés
plus de 3 millions et demi d'entrée
[Applaudissements]
sur images
je vais pas pu m'en empêcher je croyais
avoir été clair
c'est pas mal ça
[Rires]
on est venu s'amuser sur ce plateau
c'est magnifique
puis-je je l'adore
[Musique]
j'avais une tâche noire sur un sweet
blanc et qui savait récupérer ou pas non
c'est mort
je t'embrasse quand même
si vous n'avez pas encore été voir
et ils viennent juste pour le kiff parce
que quand 3 millions et demi tu t'en
fous tu fais plus qu'une télé toi je te
le dis trop mignon et demi voilà tu
viens pas les gars c'est incroyable
qu'est-ce que je suis non mais je ne
sais pas comment je suis content si vous
savez que je regarde les chiffres tous
les jours tu as plein de gars du cinéma
Jean-Michel
à côté de chez moi sympa qui me disait
bah ça marche bien
c'est pas incroyable mais c'est
incroyable surtout que même pas que pour
nous même pour le cinoche en général
parce que c'est après le covid et tout
le monde se posait la question est-ce
que cinéma c'est terminé avec les
plateformes tu sais ce que les gens sont
habitués aux séries et là c'est vraiment
cool il y a pas que nous tu vois Astérix
a bien marché aussi là il y a Creed
enfin il y a plein de films qui marchent
donc le cinéma ensemble
on a mis de l'argent dans les deux films
qu'on est plus content sur un film que
sur un autre mais voilà les gens
retournent au cinéma et ça c'est
important
dimanche à partir de dimanche aussi pour
le cinéma je dis ça il y a le Printemps
du cinéma c'est super dimanche lundi
mardi je crois 5 euros la place
non mais c'est incroyable tu pensais
faire autant ou pas on va pas du tout je
sais tu étais venu tu m'avais dit
plus de 3 millions
sur la vie des gosses arrête mais je
crois que c'est que depuis baby-sitting
je crois que tu t'es jamais gouré sur un
pronostic
non mais je te jure babything tu as dit
plus de 2 millions on avait fait plus de
2 millions le 2 + 3 millions est fait
plus de 3000 là tu es fort
sur les meufs moins fort mais
cache pas que tu vois ou pas non mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai tu vois souvent tu
vois et meuf me disent occupe-toi de
l'oseille laisse-moi t'occuper de
l'amour c'est vrai on a même fait un
recap sur le succès on le fait jamais ça
un récap sur un succès la dernière fois
qu'on l'a fait c'était pour TPMP people
le samedi
avec Mathieu Delormeau tu es content
ouais très en plus je les adore non mais
les mecs vous méritez tellement je vous
jure mais c'est vrai non mais
franchement parce que c'est pas ils
arrivent ils se la raconte
tu les vois en direction fait deux
entrées non mais c'est rigoler ils sont
tranquilles ils se prennent pas la tête
il me salissent les t-shirts
je t'adore
et avant tout
Philippe lacheau et ses partenaires
deviennent alors inséparables la troupe
devient culte et enchaîne ensuite les
comédies à succès
[Musique]
et après alibi.com les comédiens sont de
retour au cinéma avec alibi.com 2 sortie
en février dernier le film sort moi je
dis minimum 2 minions le film qui
connaît un véritable carton un même été
au-delà de cette prédiction avec déjà
plus de 3 millions d'entrées
une comédie la rente toujours à
l'affiche qu'il est possible de voir
grâce au printemps du cinéma pour fêter
le succès du film la bande à Fifi est de
retour sur notre plateau
sur ma vie et sans rien je suis très
très content ça monte hein
avec tout si on prend tous les films
vous commencez à mon avis vous commencez
à être dans le top 20 des acteurs qui
ont fait le plus d'entrée je vais le
faire le calcul d'homme moi j'ai rien à
[__] ce soir
je vous jure que c'est vrai Élodie
incroyable
on réalise pas encore entièrement mais
Elodie elle est habitué de c'est la fête
est-ce qu'on a fait au bon Dieu 12
millions
tu dois être dans le top 10 des actrices
de la chance Daniel elle se fait Ken
après un résultat du SMIC ça c'est pas
de la chance la chance il faut la
provoquer je suis désolé de la chance
c'est pour ceux qui n'ont pas de talents
Elodie je veux que je te dise la vérité
tu mérites toujours presque tu as tu
arrives tu peux toujours
elle est très drôle c'est à dire que
c'est vrai elle arrive tu vois et c'est
rare
non mais il y a un truc parce que là
elle a une image sage et cetera on a
l'impression que c'est un petit ange
mais c'est sheitana elle c'est un truc
je te jure que c'est vrai à chaque fois
qu'il y a des coups de crasse sur un
plateau c'est elle
pour amuser la galerie je suis sympa
mais c'est une chute un ado
je parle français
attention
ça va Sophie oui ça va très bien
je suis content bien sûr
c'est le chef des sports
aussi non non non
[Rires]
je suis très gêné d'avoir taché
il y avait pas de tenue
parce que pour fêter les 3 millions et
demi d'entrer plus d'ailleurs parce
qu'on va arriver à 4 millions
c'est incroyable je vous dis 4 millions
c'est absolument incroyable et tout tout
le monde je pense que moi que vous avez
même faire ouais je pense 4 4 4 4 et
demi avec le printemps du cinéma
on n'est pas contre à combien tu étais
contentes à combien j'ai été content non
mais enfin ce que fou c'est que le
premier avait fait 3600000 d'entrée et
comme enfin on s'est dit on a fait ça
une fois dans notre vie c'est incroyable
tu vois c'est c'est exceptionnel donc
on est très très mignon sur euh il va y
avoir un 4 donc alors
il va avoir un 3 ou pas on sait pas on
va voir si on a des bonnes idées faut
qu'on ait des bonnes idées à mon avis
vous allez avoir un de bonnes idées je
suis sûr tu vas le faire le 3 c'est où
tu es obligé bah on aimerait bien
ouais c'est sûr c'est sûr ça va toi tu
tombes quand là tu vas tu devrais pas
partir au Mexique ça y est on vient de
rentrer du Mexique
vous étiez à Toulouse avec vous
mais non mais pas du tout parce qu'elle
sortait avec un Mexicain oui c'est vrai
gravière
un petit peu comme ça
et genre elle s'est embrouillée avec lui
tout ça et elle m'a dit de venir au
Mexique je me suis embrouillée avec des
Mexicains ils étaient 11 mexicains
ils m'ont mis des coups de moustache
quand tu connais
dans ta galère
pas trop ça n'est pas vanté
un jour elle était dans la même piscine
que moi non je dis de sortir
parce que elle est très jolie vous
n'êtes pas
trop c'est un faux délire déjà des
traits blanches de peau ah bon un
caprice
de pied quoi c'est vrai qu'elle te fait
les ongles de pieds
il y a un truc après
l'histoire mais j'ai entendu que tu
avais dit elle m'a fait les pieds non il
a pas dit
tu as parié là
tu nous racontes tellement d'histoires
c'est [__] ce qui est vrai
mais je te le dis vous n'êtes pas trop
je te dis que c'est parce que c'est si
tu dis que c'est pas frais je te dis et
j'ai même vu Cameron Diaz
[Applaudissements]
moins fraîche parce qu'elles ont plus de
40 ans
vas-y dis une fraîche
américaine
tu nous fais chier là c'est toi qui me
demande mais je t'ai rien demandé moi tu
m'as demandé
vous vous disputez pour Eva Longoria
là-bas elle est tellement magnifique
ça va ouais et toi
[Rires]
j'aimerais qu'on revoit la bande-annonce
du film voilà alibi.com 2 parce que
trois millions et demi d'entrée qu'il a
été le voir au cinéma vous l'avez vu au
cinéma Sophie a été le voir avec mes
garçons
donc ils adorent Geri ma chérie c'était
top j'ai trouvé ça super merci beaucoup
mais j'adore bonne critique vraiment
sur le sexe tu me poserais je me fais
penser à ne pas te poser une question
cinéma non c'est vrai tu as déjà Ken
dans un cinéma
quel film boule et billets
bah c'est bien trouvé
moi je l'ai fait arrête tu l'as pas fait
[Rires]
non non j'étais jeune et je crois que
c'était un film de guerre je me rappelle
pas de guerre top guns des deux
expériences il y a très longtemps
je suis très gêné
là ils sont gênés
pour PEP qui est un très grand
réalisateur mais ça avec boule et Bill
j'ai pas accroché quand je l'ai vu et
j'ai mieux accroché sur mon voisin
[Applaudissements]
Vard
les [__] tu vois on avance
je les connaissais pas on est discuté de
maman il m'a dit je m'ennuie moi
au cinéma
je le connaissais j'étais avec trois
potes et le dernier qui était à
l'arrange et là je connaissais pas
arrête donc tes trois fois tu vas
regarder de faire le mec à côté pendant
2 minutes on est gay et alors et alors
pas une raison pour faire ça dans le
salon
[Applaudissements]
on va avoir la bande-annonce du film
allez le voir beauté des rencontres
c'est tout pas encore allé regarde
d'être mettez-moi non je suis la femme à
plusieurs heureuse du monde et bien sûr
de toi pour ce mariage il avait quand
même construit tout un alibi pour aider
ton père avoir une maîtresse c'est vrai
que c'était un petit peu limite de sa
part
en fait ma belle-famille veut absolument
que mes parents soient présents au
mariage ah merde ce n'est pas moi le
problème c'est ton escroc de père
psychopathe de merde
mais si tu as honte on peut faire un
allié de famille on loue des faux
parents comme on a fait pour le fils de
Francis Lalan hors de question les alibi
c'est terminé
j'arrive pas à croire qu'on soit là mais
c'est impossible on a jamais fait une
mission si risquée ça va se passer comme
sur de la crème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
profite de cette journée elle va être
mémorable
je vous souhaite d'être un modèle de
bonheur et de fidélité comme les ta mère
et
[Applaudissements]
avec Philippe avec Didier Bourdon avec
bien sûr qu'avec Élodie fontanquer
ordinaire franchement et gros gros
casting et gros gros films incroyable on
fête aujourd'hui les plus de 3 millions
et demi d'entrée je sais que tu adores
cette boîte cette équipe j'adore cette
bande les enfants vous adorent enfin
vous allez voir je t'adore et je pense
que le succès aussi dû à aux autres à
l'autre génération bien sûr un énorme
succès parce qu'ils sont tous
extraordinaires dans le film mais
c'était le choc des générations qui fait
que tout le monde peut y aller
dès le début c'est vrai que tu as fait
ça sur des il tendances en fait c'est un
kiffe tu tournes avec ceux qui t'ont
donné envie de faire ce métier tu vois
que ce soit Didier Bourdon Gérard Jugnot
c'est incroyable en plus là où je suis
très fier c'est la première fois qu'ils
jouent dans un film ensemble et Nathalie
Baye de quoi évidemment et tu veux que
je te dise moi j'ai une anecdote à te
raconter qui est nul mais tu vas me dire
sur moi j'étais avec un ami Laurent et
tout à l'époque qui produisait
l'arnaqueur et il me dit je vais
certainement travailler avec Philippe et
il m'a montré ta scène dans l'arnaqueur
c'est vrai c'est toujours que c'est vrai
et je lui ai dit je tu pourrais lui
demander je lui ai dit lui il va faire
carton sur carton tu avais une petite
scène je te jure que c'est vrai j'ai à
tout le monde que j'avais le premier
rôle dans le film parce que j'étais le
premier qu'on voyait ouais c'est ça
exactement
je te jure que c'est vrai tu lui
demanderas et je dis tu vas voir et je
lui ai dit tu vas voir ça va il va il va
il va
à écrire tout ça on l'aime fort mais
c'est fou enfin tout ce qui nous arrive
parce que je me rappelle encore à chaque
fois je repense quand je te vois même à
la télé nos débuts enfin on a commencé
au Morning Live un peu je me rappelle
tous les deux on s'est fait je me suis
fait virer avant toi et après tout ce
qui s'est passé derrière c'est ouais
c'est c'est tellement heureux pour vous
parce que je le tiens à le dire c'est
des amours de mecs qui boss qui font
voilà et franchement on est on est il y
a des succès voilà qui nous rendent plus
heureux et celui-là on était comme des
fous chaque jour je regardais les
chiffres chaque semaine je faisais un
petit point et j'étais comme un fou ça
cartonne vraiment pas où je suis
tellement heureux parce que vous le
méritez et vraiment vraiment mérité
c'est un bonheur et franchement les
seuls
vraiment alors
oui moi j'ai tellement aimé le film que
je suis allé voir deux fois il y a une
scène culte avec Didier Bourdon qui est
nul on l'a vu dans la bande-annonce moi
j'ai une question est-ce que c'est
vraiment lui qui est nul parce que ça
son vrai boule non c'est François
Hollande
[Applaudissements]
tu me regardes bizarrement
il faut que il faut qu'on se parle
d'accord on a des choses à se dire
c'est actuellement je pense l'un des
plus beaux acteurs du de en France je
suis d'accord
il est avec moi là
donc ça y est tu assumes non pas du tout
en amitié on forme une équipe de sport
non non merci
[Rires]